in this problem a given cylindrical dual
media drinking water filter is to be
cleaned using an air wash the filter has
a diameter of 10 ft and a depth of
4T the recommended airf flow rate for
this filter is
235 standard cubic feet per
minute what is the rate that air washing
can
occur in standard cubic feet per minute
per square foot
so there is not much useful information
about filters in the reference manual
with respect to this
problem however there does not need to
be since we can look at the units
provided by this problem to understand
what we need to solve for general info
on media filtration can be found in
section
6.9.4 point2 if you want to see what's
there for info related to other possible
problems and as a helpful side note like
I just said
scfm stands for standard cubic feet per
minute the word standard refers to flow
at standard conditions such as
temperature and
pressure anyway while that's helpful to
understand we don't actually have to
understand it to solve the problem let's
look at the units the problem is asking
us to find the air wash rate in units of
scfm per Square ft and the problem
provides us with the airflow rate of
scfm so the difference between those two
terms is the square foot
component and the problem also gives us
the dimensions of the
filter we are given a diameter and a
depth the only slight trick to be aware
of here is that we only need the
diameter and shape of the filter to
calculate the area we do not need the
depth for this problem so we can write
down our filter area as
follows the equation for the area of a
circle can be written as Pi * diameter
squ divided 4 or in this
case pi
time 10 ft^
squar /
4 which is just about
78.54 Square
ft and now all we simply have to do for
step
three is solve for what the problem
asked
for so we can divide
scfm
by
78.54 square
ft and that's going to give us just
about
three
scfm per square feet which we can see is
our first answer over
here so this is a simple problem that
throws one small trick at you with
respect to the shape of the filter but
otherwise can be solved without the
reference manual using only the units
provided in the problem and that's
[Music]
it